started on live stream. Jumping the out. I'm jumping the out.
I'm calling Ape Creek. I'm calling Ape Creek already. Exactly.
That's exactly He did that. That's exactly how it went. That's
crazy. Exactly right. You wouldn't think he'd do that. You know,
you think he'd show a little respect for Nicholas Deoro who built
half of his platform for him. Very true. He picked up half a
sag off. Destiny dropped him. Destiny dropped Chud and Chud was
actually just going to kill himself. Okay. leave two orphan children
with no father. And Nicholas Dario came down in all of his infinite
roundness and wisdom and said, "Chud, I'll hold you. I'll hold
you up, okay? I'll I'll make sure that your cats." And it doesn't